[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with the
wall-crawler swinging his way back into
the MCU fans are looking forward to the
upcoming film spider-man 3 to see what
it could bring throughout this video I'm
gonna be going over my fan theory on how
it will actually be the film in which
the character crosses dimensions into
the quote-unquote venom burst through
Madame web this is based on statements
that Kevin Feige has made as well as the
upcoming Sony Slate and whilst it won't
be confirmed until we see the movie for
ourselves there is a lot of potential
here now if I get this right then there
will be some spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything that could
potentially ruin the upcoming films then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into our fan theory on
spider-man 3 okay so in the wake of the
recent announcement that Spiderman was
staying in the MCU and that there would
be a third film for the character
released in 2021 there have been a
couple of knowable statements released
by the people at Disney and Sony that
hint at how the universe could be going
upon the release of the New Deal Kevin
Feige Marvel Studios CEO said the
following when discussing the
character's future I am thrilled that
Spidey's journey in the MC will continue
and I and all of us at Marvel Studios
are very excited that we get to keep
working on it
spider-man is a powerful icon and hero
whose story crosses all ages and
audiences around the globe he also
happens to be the only hero with the
super power to cross cinematic universes
so as Sony continues to develop their
own Spidey verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold so it's
pretty clear from this that there will
indeed be some collaboration between the
two Studios that will connect the MCU in
some form or another to the Spidey verse
whether this means that characters like
venom joins the MCU or if spider-man
travels across I mentioned so the Spidey
verse remains to be seen but there is a
lot that we can take from this we
already know that Marvel are planning to
develop and flash out the idea of
multiple dimensions something that is
known in comic books as the multiverse
with the upcoming 2021 film Doctor
Strange in the multi
of madness this film is going to be
released eerily close to spider-man 3
and will probably in some form or
another tease the future film as that's
what tends to happen with the
post-credits scenes in the Marvel movies
most Marvel films drop and not to the
film that follows them in the saga and
with Doctor Strange too dropping on the
7th of May 2021 and in spider-man 3
dropping July 16 2021 it makes sense to
tie these two together in some form or
another
according to comic book calm and movie
web Kevin Feige is apparently developing
spider-man 3 as an end game for the
character that will wrap up the John
Watts trilogy with a satisfying
conclusion now whilst this doesn't
necessarily mean the end for the
character Marvel do typically tend to
keep things two trilogies both Iron Man
and Captain America received one and
then they're following appearances were
always in team ups and crossovers which
I personally think is how the character
will appear in the MCU after his third
solo film now what I believe will happen
looking at the evidence of the Madame
web movie that was announced the day
before the MCU deal broke the Internet
is that spider-man 3 will end with the
character travelling across dimensions
to the Benham base and teaming up with
the character to take down carnage after
venom loses to the bill in his solo film
of venom to those who've been alive long
enough to remember the 1990s animated
spider-man series might recall that
during one of the major storylines
Madame web took the wall crawler across
the multiverse to defeat several threats
with a gang of spider-man from alternate
realities Webb was a guide to the
webslinger
and should carnage get too big in the
venom verse Webb may call on him to help
out this would then allow Sony to go off
and develop their continued spider base
and would also allow spider-man to come
back for the team of film that we know
is confirmed as part of the New Deal
this would stay in line with the prior
entries in the MCU and also allow for
both universes to have their cake in yet
then from this point onwards similar to
both Iron Man and Captain America though
Spidey doesn't get his own standalone
film he is there to pop up in crossover
movies such as the reported Secret Wars
Avengers film that is being worked on as
well
Civil War to which I hope goes ahead
with spider-man acting as the Iron Man s
character facing off against Captain
Marvel now whilst this is all purely a
fan theory at the moment I think if we
look at the formulas that Marvel has
used in the past with characters who've
had their own trilogies and also the
Hulk who's owned by Universal and makes
sense for the webhead to operate in this
way he will still be connected to the
MCU ads will the venom burst
though only through a technicality and
therefore it will allow both studios to
pick and choose which characters to use
and may allow venom to jump over to the
MCU and so on going off the official
statements I think we are definitely
shaping up for a lot of crossovers and
Sony are slowly building up to the
sinister six so it makes sense that
Marvel Studios would want to cash in on
this and have the to franchise connected
so that it becomes more and more
required watching if you want to stay up
to date with everything that's going on
I believe that the two corporations will
want to keep their partnership as long
as possible and with Madame web 100%
getting a solo movie this makes a lot of
sense now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this so drop them in
the comment section below and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of what the entire sony disney contract
entails i go over the possibility of
venom being in the MCU and breakdown
inside a report on everything we can
expect so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come chat to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books so make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect way to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this I also just wanna let you know that
we're currently giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on my
fan theory in the comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th at the Bureau be
shipped out from then tip against
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like click subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you